everyone this is kevin from the chess
website calm today we're in round 9 the
championship round of the 2015 Norway
Chester American pears day just so
happened to be 1 & 2 in the rankings why
it's gonna be played by so Clough he has
a small advance she has a half a point
lead on vision on his opponent playing
the black pieces serve lob gets a tie or
he wins he's gonna be the champion of
this tournament officiant non wins he
does have to win he can't tie if he does
win then machine on will be the champion
so quite a bit at stake on this game so
we will go ahead and get into a tip-off
starts out with pawn to d4 Knight f6
pawn c4 pawn East six and then Knight to
f3 actually the same opening structure
the tipple have played against yesterday
when he lost to an HD read when he was
playing the black pieces so I guess he
saw this from white and said hey I'll
try this out in my next round against
vision on
now pawn to d5 and then Knight to c3 so
changing it up a little bit from what's
he faced yesterday in round 8 but
playing Knight to c3 and then the
bishops gonna come down here to b4 and
this is the rago's in the defense in the
Queens gambit declined line a very solid
line from both it's not too crazy though
it's more of a draws line than anything
but Bishop here to a g5 pinning down the
night and then exchange off the board
why it's completely okay with the
exchanging as much material aboard again
if he gets its high he's going to win
this tournament so that's kind of his
game plan right here pawn here to e3
solidifying this pawn structure right
here Castle in the Kings side it was a
little bit thinking that this unum would
go ahead and just take with his Bishop
here on a c3 and recapture with the pond
but decided to instead play castle on
the King side now we're Cove here to see
one protecting the knight so that if the
bishop does take now on c3 there won't
be a double pawn on a DC file now vision
on takes with this pawn here on c4 not
my favorite move this allows after the
pawn takes the bishop coming up here to
take here on c4 black has given up one
of
central ponds and he's allowed his
opponent to gain a tempo in the center
of the board I usually like in this
Pacific position Knight to c6 that way
it kind of forces your opponent's move
white wants to castle on the kingside
but he may get his bishop involved first
so doesn't matter if he comes to e2 or
d3 let's say d3 from here if black
wanted to take with c4
then after white takes on c4 white had
to move had they use an extra move and
all of a sudden black now has the night
here on c6 and has an extra moves who
could play Bishop here to d7 if you
wanted to get this rook involved to e8
or d8 if you wanted too many different
options but all of these I think are a
little bit better than coming back here
and immediately playing upon taking here
on c4 it's not a horrible move but I do
think there is a small improvement by
playing something else but after Bishop
feared taking on c4 gaining that little
tempo pawn to a c5 just a little nice
outpost here both the Bishop and pawn
play very nicely together castle on the
King side after the pawn takes Knight
taking here on a d4 opening up at this D
file right here a bishop here to d7
Queen to b3 attacking this bishop here
also protecting this bishop here on a c4
Knight to c6 again as we talk about why
it's completely okay exchange of
material and that's what we see start to
happen here Bishop down here taking on
c3 rooked capturing on c3 Bishop here to
see six and then Bishop here to b5
looking to exchange off the bishops on
board and then just get into a queen and
rook in game machine on decides to come
here to d5 and then we see a little bit
of a repeats here and then we see a
threefold repetition meaning we've seen
the same setup on board state three
times in a row and so this is going to
be a drawn game was a little
disappointing that machine on didn't go
for the win
only after 18 moves it was a drawn game
so congratulations table lofty wins a
fantastic tournament mission on does
secure him
the tie for second place again with
Nakamura so he played extremely well I
really was cheering for him to do
something crazy and maybe come out with
a win at the end but all in all second
place with such a great field is always
something to be proud of so
congratulations to all the competitors a
really cool tournament to see so many
good players out here and have enjoyed
doing commentary on every round for the
most part so hopefully you guys have
enjoyed and I'll see y'all in the next
tournament thanks for watching